ja das sind sie dynasty da unten sofort
offen claudia man später etwas auf nein
ich gehe aus dem plan setzt pass auf
pass auf
da ist nix vereins winkel möglich so die
nächste folge bricht an der pause geriet
musste gleich weniger schnallten wo bist
du
ich bin über die natürlich wieder mit
mir und luca es geht weiter ich würde zu
gern den spot baum platt machen
natürlich wollen restart machen ein
kleine riester rhein kann restart
verlieren wir noch was nein
weiter bis so so wolle man lang
verzeihung ich weiß wo dehner und so
waren und da habe ich ja zwei teams
gesehen
achso her das heißt unsere kisten waren
hier und von da aus kann ich also war
das schwejk nach links okay so ach so ja
über den gibt jetzt erst weiter ich
mache jetzt schon weiter busacca also
hier ist mein weg punkte das ist so geil
aus dem hut
so können sie denn sein also die waren
genau da genau wo da waren jetzt wenn
wir genauso schräg lang gehen bis zur
kante und dann links da war sind ganz
viele brunnen dörfer oder was ist dörfer
kleine häuschen und dort wahnsinn hinter
dir vor ich freu mich so auf meine neuen
pc er kommt bald raus eine komplett
reihen drei ente da was der hat nvidia
geforce gtx 680 mit vier gigabyte
auch moskitos spannend aber eben jene
mit dem denkmalpreis muss geht die
schwaben haben wir so eine geile rüstung
sogar schwerter macht uns gar nichts ist
wirklich so ich hier vorne bei diesem
großen baum der übels episch aussieht da
waren sind also eigentlich praktisch
darunter ich finde wir können ein
bisschen träumen und den fans senden
oder billig weil dafür ist nämlich am
sports nicht überlebenswichtig
altern ist schon krass heftig warum
richtige feuerholz mein fahrzeuges
rechnet kaputte grenze so wo sind sie
jetzt sicher dass die schreib mal wir
auch wenn alle welche hätten und die
nicht die war nämlich in so einem ding
wie ich hier konnte war schon jemand wo
niemand war folgen gehen können einfach
mal angehen vielleicht sind und welche
das ist eigentlich schön ausgebaut aus
diesen tier gewiss hochgegangen eisen
was haben sie übersehen
in der fläche so kommt es auch extra
nicht mitgehen können sich auch sein
aber ich glaube kommt das erste skelett
ach du scheiße keine panik ich kenne
schon dachte auch schon so auf einmal
kommt also welche hälfte man ja die
haben diamanten übersehen oh mein gott
22 diamanten ja ok bringt es sich jeder
hat er noch ein das heißt wir haben viel
das heißt man kann sich schon machen
alter das sagen wir können uns jetzt nur
eisen wir können uns jetzt reisen die
attacke machen und ob sie dann abbau und
dann haben wir einen brauch stand aber
das bringt uns das
lasst lieber gib mir nochmal zwei
diamanten gib mir einmal dass wir zwei
gefundene glauben hat jeder zwei tagen
ersatz schwert oder wollen wir aus den
vier diamanten wirklich wenn er noch aus
diamanten machen ja eigentlich nur dabei
ersatz schwert bringt gar nichts weil
wir haben nur noch immer noch 67 gegner
war das ding ist wir haben ja zwei leben
fürs team
das heißt wenn wir beide sterben sind
die leben weg das heißt wir können
respawn haben aber kein weg mehr und
damit würden wir sagen die vier
diamanten lagern wir unseren geheim
kisten ein
und dann haben wir nämlich wieder
diamanten ist schwerter dann sind wir
nicht ganz normal wir setzen uns direkt
unter den spot unter einem baum eine
kiste da guckt doch gar keiner nach und
da hatten wir wenn einer da steht kanada
nach einfachen sekunden auf - jede kiste
sitzen die muslimbrüder richtig gut
versteckt sein und von mir aus also ich
da wirklich dafür dass wir das direkt
beim sparen machen wir das schaut auf
keinen fall einer nacht das wenn direkt
beim bauern unter einem baum der kiste
ist wirklich also müssen den block dann
aber wieder genau richtig hinsetzen
sondern dass man wohin ich will leute
gehen einfach nur ich würd sagen wir
keine erstmal so bleibe ich denke dass
uns so schnell keiner töten gereicht
aber die haben die haben mit diesen
allem stimmt im sleep modus das kenne
ich davon in den team battles nichts hat
das einfach nur unter der erde ist da
ist die makler ist ein werk welches da
irgendwas mit der markierung es erst
nach dem berg ich werde da sind auch
noch irgendwo diamanten kann man sich
fast übersehen wie die am atlanta war
daneben glaube ich mit fackeln ja da war
eine fackel daneben wie kann man sowas
übersehen
ich habe erst gedacht dass wegen eine
falle und dahinter das nicken an welcher
wollen dass man die der mann an bord und
menschen die ein oder soll das werk
rettung kann man sei man die ist seine
natürliche bist du ich bin irgendwo bei
dir wir jetzt auf dem baum vor dem werk
ich bin auf meinem radar ich bin froh
hier direkt neben dir hier ja oder nein
hier ist natürlich will habe ich ja hier
auch ja auch matula deiner richtig
reinkommen kommt nicht mehr raus zu
sehen diese vorteile
eigentlich hätte die ganze zeit diese
komischen linien teile aller dass vier
von den
so alle glocken kohle und eisen schwer
und alten hose okay gut was aus eisen
gedroppt läuft hier ist nicht okay dass
du von dem gekommen ich hab jetzt ein
erheblicher papier kohle ganzen mist in
der tasche hier geht es noch weiter
das ist aber typisch in diamanten sucht
findet man keine dann glaub ich mich
zwei drei mal ein mal auf diamanten um
hab den diamanten und dann bitten wir
hier einfach so diamanten handele
hier geht es normal weiter hier geht's
anderem auf den berg um hier
übersichtliche agenten nach oben ja ich
komme immer zu dir hier ist bestimmt
irgendwann finden weil ich hätte auch
irgendwo presse diesen fetten baum hoch
zu gehen da ist schon was geiles
ich glaube man kann sich bestimmt den
und kann den bestimmt irgendwie abbauen
also hier ist die markierung und mein
gott da wo mein vater hat mir im zwickel
bocholter trifft ist mein eigener stil
ist das portal aufnehmen dürfen nicht
durchgehend zu legen da wieder in der
realen welt lasst einfach ich werde dich
die sind irgendwann noch diamanten
die haben nicht umsonst gesagt wenn ihr
diamanten findet kurzform von einer
markierung dann das heißt sie müssen ja
oberflächlich irgendwo diamanten gesehen
haben wir aber oberflächlich nur was
gezogen wo bist du denn ich weiß nicht
wo bist du ich bin bei diesem portal
wieder ach so ja ich wäre gelaufen
ob wir auf dem weg gehen und mal schauen
dass wir wieder so eine hürde darin
genau
pilze
hier geht's runter und es ist glaube ich
vorgefertigt ja und hier ist eine fackel
hier war jemand egal was ihr trotzdem
rein gehen wir hier nicht schon vorher
dass man das was man mir okay ich bin
sehr sauer mal ganz kurz
ich habe nun mal geguckt weil ich muss
auch müssen wir müssen wenn wir jemand
sehen wir können ja loslaufen ja
eigentlich muss man auch richtig
intensiv auf den boden draufhalten
wenn jemand kurz mal nichts liegt ich
will unbedingt auf diesen fetten bauen
darauf dass richtig richtig rechnen den
diesen fetten da wo es denn überhaupt
das einfach den vor uns nehmen das
daraufhin bei diesem wasserfluss okay
ich auch wir wollen wieder hochkommt
auch ich hab ich hab nur sieben koppel
stone glaubens einfach rein passt eine
axt aber ich wusste es wusste dass terol
ist dann kann man nämlich von dem immer
die hölzer nehmen und dann uns aber ich
höre komische geräusche soll diesen
galliani kann man hochklettern komplett
hochklettern leichter aus und wetter
hätte man jeden vierten war und weniger
abgaben handwerk im helfer des sumo egal
alter ist aber auf jeden fall das wäre
jetzt hoch können er weckt natürlich
seien abgesucht
dann starten wir von da oben erstmal
eine art überblick versuchen wir das
hinzukriegen
hier war glaube ich schon jemand hält
dessen verein umgesetzt
schauen wie ich das mache war hier ist
eine lücke ja ich kann man rein so
problemlos vor sich das dann nicht unter
fällt natürlich
allerdings ist findig
ja weil das so hoch ist man wird ein
echter gegners wirklich von esch wir
müssen wir glaube ich noch höher sind
wir fast den höchsten baum
wir sind wollen höchsten baum müssen wir
noch hoch wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen umgucken
ich freue mich jetzt so weit auch ich
würde sagen wir gucken jetzt einfach mit
opti fein rand suchen einfach irgendwo
rum wo gegner sein könnten
genau ich gehe ganz nach oben zu den
ball sehr flach ist eine special kiste
das kann doch sein wenn das schon so ein
rpg zeug ist dann ich segne euch sehr
gegner da unten sind welche ganz unten
schauen mal wo ich hingucke siehst du
das ja ich weiß wo ich sehe keine die
gramm sich da gerade ein die graben sich
rein wo die das zu bauen an beiden sind
unten drin dann können wir da drin auf
jeden versuchen dahin wo ich ihn schlage
wisse ja ich gucke da in die richtung
die frage
okay okay lasst den ok gut da müssen
jetzt den war wieder runter und pflaster
heben
links neben den baum so können wir jetzt
runter hier um hier rein debatte gibt
wir sind hier oben rein gegangen
da warten eingang schauen wir mal runter
wieder noch sind ja die habe nicht weiß
wo die erde war ich weiß auch wo die
erde war okay gut die waren die waren
auf jeder seiner stoffklasse direkt hin
also alles klar oder direkt deren
eingang mit tnt wegspringen an bomben
berichten und zwar springen das mit tnt
auf und dann laufen war 3 wird sagen wir
noch ganz unten das komplizierter sofern
das nicht nur geile idee was die entente
alter das war richtig ist wir uns ran de
thé hin bekommt gepumpt wird dann laufen
werfen und alle im team rein ja genau
einfach auf bomben anstatt einfach
abzubauen das ist viel ethischer oder
hat ein wandel
wo bist du bis hinter mir hinterher okay
gut zu meinen die schweiz sicherheit
habe zu kommen die erschwert
also das genau links neben den baum
wahrscheinlich im gras drüber gewachsen
ab jetzt kann ich noch nicht okay wir
müssen ja irgendwie drucker kommt bist
du denn hier
wo willst du hin dann dem dicken baum zu
baum brannte denn da drüber sind sie
gegangen
über die schlucht so ich dachte dieser
bei mir
war es wirklich schon zu mieten jetzt
sagen wir springen das erstmal offen
sowie gehen einfach so voller hans rein
erst kurz was fressen ein wunder zu hin
auch hier war das ja komm mit
laut tmz ich muss das erst mal kurz
suchen
das war ziemlich genau hier irgendwo
nein nein das war ein baum der dick war
das war genau links neben dicken baum
das war vielleicht fand dann auf jeden
fall hinter der schlucht so viel weiß
ich noch
ja da war dass der baum hundertprozentig
das muster gewesen sein anderer kannst
dich gewesen sein
wir können einfach mal spazieren tnt
hinsetzen gleich kommen sie denn raus
ich noch machen ja doch ich sehe sie
konnten das war hier wohl dosierte kommt
ja ich hab hier gesehen
die töten neben siegen
ja das sind sie dynasty konnten sofort
drauf packt der mann später käfers auf
nein ich gehe auf die bank setzt pass
auf passaus sieber ich bin fast tot zwei
herzen habe ich mir noch warte täglich
dicke tnt
ich habe unten gesetzt kommen hier in
capcoms deftigen diamant stücken hier
vorne ist noch eingang pass auf passaus
erstmal herzen aufladen alter das war
richtig viel ausgehalten alter ist doch
so aber hier ist der gleiche weg von
anderen seite des trans narva auffüllen
das war okay
es liegt ja der ist unter uns dahin sind
welche fakt der den titel dahinstehen
dahin stets blacks das update was ist
denn hingehen
okay ich hab jetzt drauf jetzt drauf
egal ob wir verpacken oder nicht die
haben beide nichts ja der ist haben
begonnen beschäftigt allein haben wir
einen banker ja ok erst mal sortieren
postbank der schnelligkeit beim direkt
zu uns beide rhein waren doppelt ihm das
heißt beide sind jetzt tot gail davis
flex zweimal getötet haben alles klar so
special nite wartet eine lederkombi com
informieren so der eine lebt doch noch
der war hier genau unter uns
schnelligkeit und schon gegeben ich hab
noch geschwindigkeit da gut dass jetzt
direkt auf titel gehen das stelle war
ich hier unter dem wasser
hundertprozentig jemand da ist jede
kiste sogar es erstmal die lava ihn
wieder aufbauen weil meine lover von
vorhin die haben a noch einmal die bühne
auch noch lava mit ja aber du kannst du
nichts mit ihnen passieren der fließende
lava haben wir schallplatten tnt von den
finde ich auch mal weg zum gold schwert
und stiefel sonst nichts gut da will ich
sagen soll team jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen kann es jeder war jona
prozentig unten er war hier unterm
variabler der es hundertprozentig jetzt
über alle berge gelaufen
glaub nicht vorangekommen ist so ein
schisser so wo bist du wieder an jeder
kiste ich sortiere es mal ein bisschen
ja die ganzen scheiß tue ich auch weg
den ich eingesammelt haben also viel
kann ich mitnehmen aber den rest recht
nicht hier papier das hier fahndete
bücher aber dafür brauchen wir dafür
brauchen wir so ein amboss die macht man
sich ein amboss weisen ganz hier
wir haben eisen ich habe zwölf waisen da
braucht man mehr 40 eisenbahn dafür und
braucht dafür drei eisen blöcke und dann
noch drei eisen nichteisen vielleicht
auch mal richtig viel eisen so lasse
aber wieder hochgehen
was ich hier verspritzt und
schnelligkeit und dann gehört nach oben
und de falla hat echt gebracht die
wollten uns verfolgen dass das gesehen
dann ihr ministerium muss die richtig
hoch gesamten frostig war bevor sie das
geschafft haben ich dachte eigentlich
auch wir gehen drauf weil ich hatte nur
noch zwei herzen das hatte ich noch
einen schlag gewesen um mal wieder hoch
gehen
ja das kann man lange daraufhin baum
oder was nämlich auf den baum
ich höre gerade jemand hat blöcke
gesetzt jemals die ecke kommt wieder
runter
komm runter ist niedlich und höher
wer so ein schwarm ich hoffe jemand
gesetzt blöcke hörst du das auch gehört
ich sage dir ist hier unten irgendwo da
baut sich hinter sich zu